but you know when we started we were
like the real uh
cliche of a garage startup we were two
people then we were five people and
worked in one room and uh i was stressed
all day long
like i couldn't go to sleep i wanted to
see that we're meeting our ambitious
goals and we used to start working so
early and we'd finish in the middle of
the night but
we really enjoyed it so you know we
didn't care we understood that we're
building something great
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
all the way from zdebokel to drone pilot
to now successful startup ceo meet
uri grunbaum ceo and co-founder at hip
ranks
uri is the ceo and co-founder of tip
pranks a fast-growing financial
accountability engine that helps
millions of users make better financial
decisions
in high school he moved to a boarding
school in zdebokel and then
served as a drone pilot in the idf air
force after studying computer science at
the hebrew university followed by an mba
from tel aviv university
he worked as a software engineer at
avaya convergent now oracle
and arx now docusign uri greenbaum
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
today
i'm uh doing great thank you having a
great day so far
well amazing i hope it's going to get
just a little bit better
i don't promise anything but i hope so
uri thank you very very much
for joining me from the tip pranks
offices is that where you are
right yeah here near uh rockfield in tel
aviv
beautiful i see the the amazing logo
right there on the wall behind you
you know so we'll talk about tip ranks
and the really cool things you're doing
over there
but first i want to know the cool things
about uri and you as an entrepreneur and
as a learner
you know all the way from being in a
boarding school in debo
you know with ben gurion's legacy i i
can't imagine you know that's not the
most traditional
you know entrance to uh for for
high-tech people right now
uh so it's i don't have to hear about
that experience but also you know as
a drone pilot and you know you did such
cool things along your life
i just want to absorb some life lessons
from you so
so tell me a little bit about your
journey what you went through and and
how that led you
to being to decide that you want to be
an entrepreneur and create a company
like tip rings
sure so it's uh it's an interesting
question and you know the journey uh
actually involves a lot of
things that i've done before so i uh i
was born in jerusalem we moved to san
francisco pretty early
on then i moved to a neighborhood called
which is near jerusalem and you know i
think that when i was about 11 years old
i found my first job
we had a cake uh garage in our street
and i used to go there and help the
people who moved the cakes to their
trucks before they actually distributed
in the neighborhood
and uh so that was basically
my first job and after that i'd used to
build some cool stuff from fimo
and sell them and you know i used to uh
pick uh salvating i don't know how you
say that in english but we used to sell
them as well me and friends
and you know then we grew up i started
working i worked at construction i
worked at a bookstore i booked it and i
worked at an ice cream shop
and uh i basically gained a lot of
experience doing a lot of different
things
when i was in high school i moved to
step of care because i had a lot of
passion
for animals and for country and
traveling and
my parents agreed for me to move a few
hours from home
you asked to go to a boarding school in
the middle of the desert
uh from the jerusalem area and you know
that was probably one of the
most fun parts of my life because
anybody who ever visited stem or care
can probably agree that it's the most
beautiful place in israel
now the best thing about the bokeh is
the people that live that live there
uh they have such high morals and it was
so
you know it was such an experience to go
and meet people that are so different
than you know how i grew up
and uh you know i took a lot of things
from my experience over there first of
all living with people you know in the
same room but 24 7 and knowing
learning how to get along with people
that are so different
from you and you know to become friends
of people that you would never
otherwise meet um you know a lot about
care was about uh traveling loving the
country it was like the other side of
capitalism it's kind of a kibbutz in the
negev or the only thing you care about
is
uh basically turning the negative into
uh into a flourishing place
um so you know when i left double care
the last thing that i thought about was
high tech
i you know we had a computer school back
then and we connected to the modem and
we learned all that but it was so
far away from me and i remember that we
saw
like in the early 90s there was a movie
called uh
sneakers with uh robert redford where
they hacked all these places and you
know i remember seeing that and it
really blew my mind
uh and that was probably the first time
that i was really thinking about
technology
so you know after school we went to the
army and uh i started at the air force
uh you know i tried being a pilot but uh
it didn't go too well for me
and so uh i was moved to a drone unit
back then it was called the uav
an unmanned air vehicle and we used to
fly them and that was
such a fun thing to do you get to see so
many interesting stuff
in you know in other countries but also
in israel
and you are involved in uh unique
operations
that you know i'm still amazed that you
know
people at the age of 18 19 20 get so
much responsibility and get access to
to these you know amazing activities
um and you know that was probably the
first time that i had some access to
real technology where you have to learn
and understand how things work
complicated systems anywhere from gyros
aerodynamics and you know how you can
put inside electricity just to make
something work
um after that you know i traveled a bit
like uh most of my friends traveled in
asia and then in central america
and um went to university
and because i did not know what i want
to do when i grew up
and you know you might say that i still
don't know what i want to do when i grow
up
um i want to study computer just because
i thought that it would help me find
jobs pretty easily
when i uh graduate and uh
university i also met my uh my other
co-founder in this company
we study together and you know
that's how i started that's how i got
into the space of high tech i worked at
other companies i
uh you know i was lucky enough to work
for a few startups that did an exit i
worked for big corporate american
companies
and i always wanted to be an
entrepreneur actually when we were in
university we took a course in
entrepreneurship and the last year you
get to choose some courses that are not
you know hardcore software
um and so i got to meet a lot of uh
established entrepreneurs that gave us
presentation and it was really
motivating
and you know i i think that back then i
knew that i want to be an entrepreneur
one day and you know since that course
in university 20 years ago it was in me
i you know one of the things that i see
today
and i'm you know i'm really excited to
hear your point of view on this
you know we grew i grew up in a place
where entrepreneurship is sort of yours
the second word you you say right when
you're born if you're born into
you know in in specific places around
the world and you see it around you
you know in first grade i remember that
i i had the pleasure of being in palo
alto
in third grade and living there and i
remember that
the person who invented the the
playstation 3 came and brought us
a you know a beta version full of wires
to
to for show and tell it was crazy and i
remember as a kid i'm thinking like wow
like
i get to see this playstation 3 before
and and
this is like an entrepreneurship is is
the place to be
now you go to the bokeh yeah drone pilot
goes to the university
you know entrepreneurship is obviously
you know a thing of israel but
it doesn't it doesn't seem like it's a
center point or a focal point for you
on your journey how how do you how do
you perceive that
you know coming into this world a little
bit later but
but with a different understanding and
different you know core
and balance how do you perceive that so
you know i think that
um one of the most important things that
you need in order to succeed unless of
course you are a virtuos or you know
you're mark zuckerberg and you don't
need anything because
uh you're just lucky um
but but what i think that the average
entrepreneur needs is uh to get along
with people
is to uh motivate them and to share your
dreams and to dream big of course and
bring everyone with you as it's the
ability to convince other people
and it's the ability to be grateful
because when you're an entrepreneur you
usually
have a lot of people that will just help
you out during the way people that works
in institutions that want to bring you
in
people that know what they're doing and
just want to help you because they
appreciate what you're doing
and these are things that i've learned
instead of care
in high school how to get along with
basically anyone because you don't
really have
any other option and of course in the
army as well you know
serve with with many people you live
with them they're like your family for
many years
and in the army you also get to see so
many different people
um that come from so many different
cultures and
and all that so i i really i feel like i
really took that
with me and i was able to channel that
uh to create a network to meet with
you know other entrepreneurs and and
to help sell our product when the time
was right and we had a product that we
could actually sell
and and that brings us to to tip pranks
so
where are we you're we're i'm i'm
feeling i feel like i'm in your office
so we have amazing offices that are raw
field here we're now on the first floor
but we have two floors
uh the thing is that most of the
employees are now working from home so
you know
it's usually just me and a few other
people at the office
um but yeah we moved here a few years
ago beautiful place we took a bauhaus
building completely and
just moved the entire company there but
it's now getting a bit small for us
and soon we will be moving to other
offices
wow so tell me a little bit about you
know the founder journey
with your co-founder through tip rings
you're you come to an understanding that
there's this gap in the market
specifically in in the investment world
whether it comes to
you know the accessibility to
information the insights from that
information and making
decisions what what is the the essence
of tip ranks
as it when it comes to to know the way
that it interacts with people's behavior
so you know when we started the company
nine years ago uh
the gap that i found was that there was
no one to tell you if advice you're
getting online with any good
you can't go on any website in israel or
in the us or anywhere in the world
without seeing a lot of articles about
what
different experts are saying and
you know retail investors such as myself
we're so responsive to this content
because we don't really know the market
you know it's not our day job and we
trust
experts from the big banks to give uh
you know to give a reliable
um insight so
that was missing and we developed this
really cool browser add-on and
that was you know the vision of the
company that we will have something
sitting on your browser and wherever you
browse you're going to get
a report where you will be able to click
on the browser's button and get a report
about whoever is writing the story and
how after it is
and the concept was huge and our first
product was also amazing but it was very
difficult to scale
or monetize a browser add-on business
and so two years after we did a complete
pmoc and we moved from being a browser
add-on into a website
and that was uh that was a very big
challenge because
when we had a browser ad on the story uh
was pretty good i mean you uh you
integrate us one time and then you can
use us whenever you want when you're
browsing during your browsing experience
and when we switched into having a
destination website which is what we did
in 2014
um you know suddenly the narrative
wasn't very clear for us because now we
expect people to actually come to our
website
and to um you know to do research before
they're making investment decisions so
we took a very big bet
uh but it paid off it paid off big time
because
it took us some time to get to the first
users you know you're doing a lot of
marketing hacks anywhere from writing
comments social media and stuff like
that
and over time we took it from a few
thousands of uh
monthly users to a few hundreds of
thousands to uh
monthly users and now to a few millions
of monthly users
and the market is so big so we expect to
get to a few tens of millions of monthly
users
and as you're seeing this growth
how do you how do you change how does
your perception
of either tip rings as a company or you
as an individual how how does that how
does that change
so you know we started almost nine years
ago so
i think that everybody would change even
if i wasn't that temperance and i
wouldn't have done nothing i would uh
you know like
the things i would look out or my
philosophy would have changed over time
but you know when we started we were
like the real uh
cliche of a garage startup we were two
people then we were five people and
worked in one room and uh i was stressed
all day long like i couldn't go to sleep
i wanted to see that we're meeting our
ambitious goals and we used to start
working so early and we'd finished in
the middle of the night but we really
enjoyed it so you know we didn't care
we understood that we're building
something great and
you know now when we we are uh much
bigger and more profitable
and you know we are we feel very
comfortable about our product we always
want to improve it
but i guess that you know the things
that i'm looking at are very different
when we started i did everything i did
support i did qa i helped coding of
course i found investors and i did what
a ceo should do but but i
really did everything and slowly you're
bringing more people and you're
delegating your job
and that allows you to spend more time
on creating the vision and looking you
know on the big picture down the line
and so i'm much less uh stressed
than i was a few years ago and
i still enjoy uh what i'm doing i think
at the same level but it's different
challenges you know it's one challenge
to build a product
it's a second challenge to me to get to
a product market fed and then it's a
different challenge to scale that and
when you're at a point
uh that we are now the other challenges
is what else can we create we have all
these users we have a strong brand
what complementary products can we
create what other markets can we go into
um are there companies that are
interesting enough for us to buy that
could help us speed things up
and so the challenges are very different
and you know i feel very lucky
to uh to have you know the privilege to
go through all these
uh phases when we started the company we
thought it would be a two-year thing we
thought we would build a company and
after two years we will either uh sell
the company or
you know at least we would know if it
makes sense to dedicate our life
to this but uh as time flies understand
how big
is uh what you're building and the
impact that you're making so
you know there is no urge or any need
from anyone including our investors to
even think about
uh exiting this and the vision you know
is just to become the
market leader in uh research
i love that and i have to say one of the
things that
how many people are you today at the
pranks in the company
so we are 66 employees and we are
recruiting
uh and uh i believe that we will pass
the 100 employees by the end of this
year
like every day we i see new people in
the office and it's just unbelievable we
used to be so small
and you know you knew everybody you knew
they're the the names of their kids
their wives
their husbands and you know now uh you
just like
see people uh walking in the kitchen and
you say hi and they say hi nobody knows
who
you know who the other guy is and it's
uh it's funny and nice and uh you know
it's just a
phase that uh companies need to go
through of accelerated growth not just
with a product but also with the team
and then i i have to say that honestly
or one of the things that i'm
you know i really enjoy it sounds so
grounded and so
balanced and and calm and and honestly i
wish that for myself
you know i wish that when i'll be in a
fast-growing company
of almost 70 people growing you know
almost
1.5 x in a matter of months that i'll be
as common grounded as you are
and then i can tell you that you will
you will because you don't have any
other
option you can't you can't afford to be
expressed anymore
at the beginning you know you need to
take care of two three fires every day
so you're you know you're running around
the fire thinking how can you solve it
and if it
killed the business or not but you know
as you grow you understand that you need
to take
care of 50 fires every day and so it
becomes you know you get to a place
where you can't really stress about
everything because you don't even have
time
and so you can lay back and you also
realize that nothing is really going to
kill your business
because you know it's a stable business
and it's just in your head all the
things that
always freaked me out and scared me were
uh you know were completely like
when when you zoom out and when i
reflect about the times that i was you
know completely depressed about things
going on these were probably the best
times of the company
in terms of the business that's where we
grew the most and all that
and so i know that you know i can
probably uh
run around here angry because this
didn't happen that didn't happen and you
know he didn't beat tesco and that goal
but you know what am i going to get from
that
lori this was amazing thank you i have a
few
last questions for you are you ready
yeah
all right favorite subject in school
hmm so it kind of changed over time i
remember
that um so first of all i was pretty bad
in math
and in physics and i remember that when
i
joined the air force we had to study
that and it was difficult for me as well
and you know after the army i had to
improve my grade so i did uh five units
physics and five units math and
i got my very high scores in both and
that's when i realized how much i love
physics and so you know in school i
liked with with the gym with the sports
because i love doing sports
uh but you know
the subject that i really like and
wished i liked it back then so i could
enjoy it a bit more is physics
i love it i love it one of your role
models or somebody that you look up to
so you know in our uh small ecosystem in
israel there are many people that i look
up to
but if i had to choose the one person
that i think would be the
leonardo da vinci of our time it is
obviously elon musk like nobody is
making a bigger impact than him he
it goes into uh areas that no one
touched for hundreds of years and he
completely disrupts it so i can't see
how you can
how can someone not look at you know
elon as a
role model wonderful and three words
that you would choose to describe
yourself
or if i would ask anybody to pranks who
is uri
um so i'd say that you know i'm uh
i'm a kind and a good person like i like
helping
it's that's one of the things that i
found that make me happy
i am grateful i
honestly i think you know if i had to
give one tip to entrepreneurs is be
grateful thank people that help you
during the white because it goes a long
way and you have an amazing roi
on the word thank you and um
the third property um
i don't know um happy
i guess i don't know because you know
we're all happy most
but i guess i'll go with that i can it
definitely comes through
and this conversation ori thank you very
very much best of luck with the pranks
um just amazing i look forward to coming
and meeting you in person hopefully in
the new offices and
and and you know seeing the amazing
thing you're building thank you for the
inspiration over these 20 minutes
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you michael it was a pleasure take
care and you are of course invited
thank you
[Music]